i wa of course i want to talk can we
talk about that when i was mad at you
what
how mad oh my god i would not oh i
wanted to end her
i wanted to end her [ __ ] career oh
wait was it the chelsea thing yeah
oh i know this story yeah i can't wait
to talk about it yeah yeah
so i i want to say this all right i i
literally had to
think about like you know i mean think
about it before i even
brought it up yeah so it's it's so it's
been far in the past that i don't even
think about it right
and number two i love you a lot yeah i
[ __ ] hated you though
and uh so we do the ch i would like to
hear your side of the story okay okay
okay okay
so i'm oblivious by the way of him even
being mad at me
i mean now i know obviously because he
screamed at me publicly in front of so
many people
did i really so she really yes in the
hall of the comments i was
so surprised i did not think you were
mad at me okay so
doing chelsea lately was the most
stressful [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean i i've never been more nervous to
do anything in my life
because it was it was just very tense
like i get there i've never met
uh chelsea before i think i've done it
like two or three times by the time i
did it with you yeah
but when i first i didn't know chelsea i
was flying in from new york to do it
they were like don't look at her like
don't look her in the eye but look near
her and don't like and they're like
make sure you jump in but don't
interrupt chelsea and like all these
things like they had all these rules and
it was very stressful and
i had not been on tv before i want to
can i interject real quick
i want to just add on may i yeah the
reason why it's stressful
okay is is that you don't you you shoot
at two o'clock
and you have to go to universal city
right right and sometimes you
at noon they don't have the topics yet
oh it's so stressful right and then all
of a sudden you get these
topics right five things that have
happened right
and you have to quickly come up with
five angles or jokes
on each topic on each topic right can i
get a shout out
yes because the last two years you did
chelsea he would not wake up until like
45 minutes before and he would have nick
youssef and i
wake up really early yeah yeah just
waiting for the [ __ ] topic
yeah yeah so we could write his jokes
for him yeah right
so all right oh my god the power
dynamics
but in a show like that right like if
you do david spade's show for instance
what's it called uh
lights out lights out right you can say
a joke
and then you can turn to whoever and go
can i say that over again
right yeah and they're like yeah take it
as many times as you want
right and they can just fill in the
laughter right but with chelsea you know
you have to say it perfectly or she'll
rip you apart
and she'll not ask you back like she'll
be or she won't ask you back
or you know there's all these other
things that are at play
so now you're there right in front of a
gigantic studio audience it's so many
people so many people
it's hundreds of people and by the way i
always like a couple of my bank tellers
and stuff i always brought random people
if anyone recognized me from chelsea i'm
like do you want to come yeah
yeah you want a picture they're like
we're good yeah and so
you're there and then here's another
here's another thing is when you
come up with your bits sometimes this
happens right
you you get a writer and you have to
pitch them the bits
meanwhile in 10 minutes you're on air
and they're doing your you're not even a
girl the girl i'm in full makeup they're
they're like close your eyes i'm like i
can't they're like putting eyelashes
[Laughter]
yet they're like are you ready they're
like we're miking him like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the mic on right so
you're about to go out and they and then
somebody will come in the room and go
yeah um so-and-so is already doing that
joke but then
you're you're and then you're being hold
on to the set you go what do i do then
what the [ __ ] do i eat and then you're
like i would have it folded up i would
have my notes folded up yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah trying to like
memorize them like yeah oh my god oh my
god oh my god
yeah like i'm eyeing down yeah like
don't look down i'm like but i have my
notes are there
yeah in fact one time chelsea wasn't
there wanda sykes was there
tg miller miller and i are on the panel
right
and we remember going like she's there
they're about to go and me and tj no
wonder sucks we turned her and we go
what's up wanda and she goes like this
and that gesture [ __ ] me up
wait why did i go i don't know what i'm
doing now i don't know why
was she mimicking chelsea i think maybe
that's what she thought that
the role was chelsea would be so
different with me every time i did it
too like yeah
one time she would like like because i
didn't know her at all it was so nice
for her to put me on i cannot believe
she put me on the show
and so i was like we're walking down
this the hallway and she's like hey girl
and she would like tickle my stomach and
be like mama like
oh my god yeah like just little
old me i was like an open mic like thank
you and then and then other times she'd
walk down the hallway and she'd be like
i'm like yeah yeah was i invited here
yeah i don't know
i have to also say though that without
it
in that chunk of my life right i
wouldn't have had the numbers on the
road
it was amazing it was amazing it changed
my life
and we're grateful we're just
complaining about the stress it was just
so stressful the the timing of it
because chelsea at that point i mean i
don't know how early you did it on she
was so kind of
over she didn't want to do more takes
which actually made the show hilarious
because she'd just be fumbling through
the thing like whatever and they just
put the thing up she called me amy
lieberman like five times
yeah yeah i think she might even call me
amy schumer or let's cut to now the
night
the day we do it okay so there's all
this stress
and the um okay so i don't remember the
topics or the jokes or anything
but i remember it wasn't didn't go well
okay i remember when we got off you
could say that again
you can see well i figured out what it
was when i watched it i realized what i
didn't realize about the way you were
delivering the jokes
because i was always waiting for i was
you
you have to jump in if you don't jump in
with you you were famous okay this was
like all i had so it was like
so that's all i had too no no i agree
with that i'm not
okay no no i just i just i'm trying to
explain like
i didn't have any of like i get it i get
what you have perception camera and
stuff perception of me
your perception of me you know me is
different than the perception i have of
myself
maybe you're in your head you're like
well this guy was on a show before
right i didn't realize that you were
okay so when you delivered your jokes
you would you would you would tell the
joke possibly do an act out and then you
would look at the camera and you would
hold a look
and that was like the laughs would like
it would kill right i didn't realize the
look holding so what i was doing was i
was so obsessed with my own
getting the jokes out i would hear a
pause when it was you were like
continuing to deliver the joke
and i would think the joke was done so
then i would jump in
to get the joke but i was cutting your
joke off okay can i say this
yeah okay that's correct yeah right
but what i saw and i was a [ __ ] no no
what i saw was this
okay i would wait because i know that
you were jumping the gun
yeah so i waited for you to do your joke
first yeah right
you would do your joke first right and
in my head i'm like
okay i got the two guys out of the way
right right
now it's my turn to do my joke right
you're
you get one shot right so halfway
the first time right i did i wasn't even
even
able to tell my joke because you did
your joke
i forgot who the other guest was yeah
and then it was my turn to talk
and you did a second joke i wish i had a
joke to interrupt you
i know but you had a second joke and
then after your joke chelsea goes
okay now we're going you know commercial
break
right so now i know now i know we have
to go to the next topic
and so in that [ __ ] chunk i said
nothing
right and so i i i turned them i turned
to michael cox
and and he comes up to me and goes i i i
know i saw oh
and i go what the [ __ ] bro oh no that
was my strongest one
that was my strongest one right he's
like i know but you can't
you just deliver get get out you get out
in the first place
and the first better than i thought yeah
in the second half just get your first
joke out
right i know but everyone because i
didn't
say anything right so now you have an
external locus of control
right now we're back now now back to
right so i go okay this bit is you know
i'm going to pause
and do the punchline right because the
first one is obviously just a setup
right
so i do the setup right i do the pause
she goes right in
she goes right in and look what right no
laugh
no laugh for me right she goes right in
right
now at least and then the other comic
does it right
and then also commercial break michael
comes up to me
michael's sweating now [ __ ] because he
knows that like my eyeball why didn't he
tell me
what because we don't know because
everything's moving so fast
right everything's going so fast right
and now i'm whispering things like you
know
i'm gonna kill her that's so and i have
no clue
she has no idea what's the next topic
like i hope i remember my jokes so then
the third one
right was the worst one and this is not
your fault
i mean all right the third one's not
your fault right so mind you right i'm
on this whole show
i haven't seen anything funny yet and
i've been i've been on camera for about
20 minutes
yeah i'm just a guy that just said
sitting there right
the feeling the sinking feeling when the
commercial break comes is really it's
like
unmatched in life like you don't when
you haven't gotten your joke out wow i'm
literally also having thoughts like um
maybe i could just you know work at the
store
[Laughter]
you know i mean like not just a doorman
but like you know maybe promotions
oh right like i'm thinking your whole
life my whole life is flashing before my
eyes
right and the third one i'm i'm about to
tell the joke
and they do a thing where chelsea just
interrupts me and she goes fortune
themes to her she's even on the panel
right i think fortune fusion comes out
in like a lingerie or something and does
a dance
it was a bit that like no one was told
about it
so the whole show i [ __ ] ate it
and then i remember thinking to myself i
hate that girl
annie my number one enemy wow you know i
have a lot of enemies on the wall
right yeah but like you know she's my
number one
and then what what what did i say to you
at this point oh and then like we get
like okay so we get off stage and like
i know it didn't go great but i'm like
what you know i'm just sort of like
i don't like at this point i'm not
feeling
fully responsible i'm like we all kind
of didn't have a good show but i also
didn't know yeah yeah and then cox was
like wow that was a rough one i was like
like you know and then i was like oh
like the lights got darker and i was
like oh my god
we bomb my parents are gonna watch this
is terrible
and then um so when i see bobby at the
store later at night and i go
oh that sucks like we didn't do good and
he was like
and i was just kind of like i had no
clue like i just had no clue
right right i just like am wild i don't
there's no because it was
pinned it was like i you know i i had it
just in my chest
and everyone was like i was like and i
was like bobby i'm so sorry with net and
you're like
you're supposed to make everyone look
good and i was like i would never in
your you are trying to make me look bad
and i was like i would
never try to make you look bad right and
it was like that kind of how long
yeah how long did it take for now for me
to
to get back because i feel like to be
friends again yeah i feel like what you
did was the right thing
you did the same thing tiffany haddish
did what kimmy
had we've talked about on the show when
she was here that she betrayed me
right and then there was a
relentlessness on tiffany hatcher's part
to get me to like them again do you
think
i think you did i think there were times
right socially
right that you i just didn't know you
didn't like me ever so i was just
treating you regularly
at me once again in my head i was number
one no
no in my head i'm like wow she's crafty
really
she's probably she's probably thinking
right we're all cool now but in my head
i'm like wow she's saying hi to me and
flip
flicking my hair that's where the
self-centeredness comes in that's what i
tell you like
you always you have these hang-ups about
you think people are thinking of you
right and they're not everyone's just
moving about and doing their own [ __ ]
wait were you mad at me when we did the
nbc thing what nbc thing
remember when we did finesse williams
nbc thing remember he was doing a
oh my god this is how much you work you
piece of [ __ ]
this is how successful you are
snl i love them no i i don't remember
that but
okay freaking out you're like because
you have a thing where you're like this
is my last job every time you have a job
you were like you were like
the screaming am i bombing a little bit
is bombing
but no yeah i think you pulled your dick
i think you did get naked again but it
was like
you know what it feels like they showed
us a video and we made jokes about
right animal video or something because
but i'll tell you why
i'm only like that in in jobs where it's
like i did this wasn't a part of my
dream
right panel shows were not a part of my
dream it's not my skill set
you know i mean i've always wanted to
like i like acting and i like
sketches and i like being big and
controlling things you know
and also showing my muscle right doing
um
panel shows that's why the david is that
what you call
[Laughter]
but like so the finesse thing i don't
remember it but what happened
you just were like freaking out running
around clothes were coming off yeah
we're having a breakdown you're like oh
my god this is a big network i'm like
bobby i think it's fine you're probably
going to get several more tv shows
[Laughter]
yeah i think you're fine yeah but yeah
when did you start liking me again how
recently it took a year
oh okay that was a long time ago yeah
yeah it took about a year year and a
half i
um i just remember forgetting
oh you know and and then seeing around
what i also like about you is
observing you i always i like to observe
you
around other comics to see if other this
is so gross
i want to hear it i'm going to tell you
okay but this is a gross part of my
personality